et ce matin nous recevons l'historien du
sport Fabien Archambault bonjour bonjour
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes l'auteur de
nombreux ouvrages sur le rôle du sport
dans nos sociétés et le dernier c'est ce
livre coup de sifflet une histoire du
monde en 11 matchs aux éditions
Flammarion en réalité chaque anecdote
autour de ces 11 matchs historiques ou
tomber dans l'oubli c'est plus un
prétexte pour découvrir le poids
sociétal du foot que ce soit en France
au Brésil en Uruguay en Russie en Italie
les liens entre un sport populaire et
les sociétés pendant un siècle entre le
foot et la marche du monde c'est un
sport populaire donc le premier
demi-siècle était proche du peuple
est-ce que le foot est pas un peu en
train de de s'éloigner peu à peu du
peuple avec le foot business avec des
contrats comme peut-être celui de Mbappé
même si on n'est pas sûr des
affirmations du Parisien avec du
sponsoring outrance non en fait il a
toujours été comme ça c'est vraiment le
sport de la société industrielle
c'est que en fait il y a pas eu un âge
d'or du football où il aurait été
préservé de l'influence de l'argent il
est le produit de l'argent dès les
premiers matchs je vais vous montrer en
Angleterre c'est un business les
professionnels du cricassisent dessus
voilà si devient le sport qu'il est
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'il y a des
industriels du spectacle qui ont décidé
de le proposer comme le sport de la
modernité d'une société urbaine et
industrielle en Angleterre à la fin du
19e et comme le monde en fait va dans
cette direction c'est à dire
l'industrialisation et l'urbanisation au
contraire il est de plus en plus le
sport du monde notamment dans les
dimensions industrielles tous les pays
émergents l'Afrique l'Asie se sont eux
les futurs continents du football par
rapport au Vieux Continent comme
l'Europe alors vous racontez le premier
match de de football qui s'est déroulée
en Angleterre la première Coupe du Monde
aussi et cette finale le 30 juillet 1930
la victoire de l'Uruguay sur l'Argentine
le jour du centenaire de de l'accession
à l'indépendance de une coupe du monde
politique l'Uruguay avait tout misé sur
cet événement c'était compliqué à mettre
en oeuvre tous ces faits à lattes on a
organisé une coupe du monde en quelques
mois quelques semaines à peine à
raconter moi tout ça mais l'idée c'est
que la Coupe du Monde c'est la création
des Sud-Américains
ont vécu sous l'influence culturelle
anglaise et après la Première Guerre
mondiale ils ont besoin de refonder
leurs identités nationales c'est-à-dire
ils se disent que la civilisation n'est
pas forcément entre Paris Londres et
Berlin après la boucherie de la Première
Guerre mondiale et le football est un
moyen pour eux de se mesurer à l'Europe
en montrant qu'ils sont capables de
jouer autrement donc la Coupe du monde
en fait c'est eux d'abord qui veulent
l'organiser ils veulent que l'Angleterre
Vienne en fait la principale progression
du gouvernement revoyen c'est que
l'Angleterre vienne jouer à montevideos
oui parce que le l'ancêtre de la FIFA
leur dit on va faire ça on va faire une
espèce de semi Coupe du Monde enfin des
poules en Europe des poules en Amérique
latine depuis les meilleurs se
rencontreront les Uruguayens disent non
tout va se passer chez nous oui bah oui
c'est en fait il y aurait eu plusieurs
solutions pour faire un championnat du
monde de football pour savoir quelle est
la meilleure équipe nationale
la première solution qui existait déjà
en Europe dans les pays où qui était
déjà passé au professionnelisme c'est
des matchs toute l'année en aller-retour
et à la fin on compte les points et on
peut décider qui est la meilleure équipe
du monde mais sauf que là les
sud-américain m'a vu les distances à
l'époque et ben en gros ils ont été
exclus de ce championnat du monde la
deuxième raison c'est que il y a une
compétition qui marche dans le monde du
sport à ce moment là c'est les Jeux
Olympiques où c'est ramassé en quelques
semaines avec dans un endroit précis et
la FIFA en fait veut dupliquer ce modèle
olympique et donc choisi un moment donné
ce qui convient aux yeux d'américain de
faire une compétition tous les quatre
ans comme les Jeux Olympiques dans un
pays voir dans une une ville comme ça a
été le cas en 1930 alors dans votre
livre on découvre également que le
football s'invite dans la guerre en
connaissait ces matchs de la fraternité
pendant la Première Guerre mondiale
entre Français et Allemand vous vous
intéressez notamment à 1942 à Leningrad
assiégé par les Allemands au milieu des
bombes la Russie organise un match alors
que des pluies de bombe s'abattent tout
près du stade et la Russie et l'URSS par
la suite vont très vite comprendre
l'utilité sociétale du football pour
essayer de de rassembler et de faire
corps dans des moments difficiles
totalement c'est contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait penser le football
réussit en URSS et en fait il y a la
même chose qui ce qui se passe en Europe
de l'Ouest c'est à dire une industrie du
football alors évidemment les joueurs
sont pas officiellement professionnels
mais en fait ça l'est c'est à dire ce
sont des amateurs qui sont employés dans
les usines d'État soviétique mais qui en
fait se dédit complètement à leur
activité et en fait il y a un monde du
football professionnel qui est très
populaire dès les années en Union
soviétique et du coup bah comme tout le
dans tous les états de ce moment là
pendant le siège les lingrad il s'agit
de montrer contrairement à ce que dit la
propagande allemande que léningrades vit
encore et il s'agit d'organiser des
matchs de football avec ceux qui
tiennent debout puisque avec le gros
problème du siège à une grâce il y a le
froid et bien la fin c'est à dire qu'ils
tiennent à peine debout et en fait ça
dans la légende de la grande guerre
patriotique soviétique les footballeurs
de Léningrad
occupe une place très importante ils ont
été le symbole footballistique de la
résistance des soviétiques à l'invasion
nazi et d'ailleurs les communistes en
Italie aussi l'ont bien compris
l'intérêt de du football dans la société
de rassemblée autour des des idées en
Italie elle communisme et puis il y a
aussi l'église et vous évoquez beaucoup
l'empreinte de la religion catholique
dans le football les premiers clubs
français dans les campagnes qui
dépendent souvent du diocèse la JS en
est un héritage aujourd'hui avec un
maillot qui vous vite rappelle encore
les couleurs de la Vierge Marie en
Italie aussi l'Église catholique utilise
le football on peut même dire que si le
football est devenu le sport national en
Italie c'est parce que l'église après la
fin du fascisme a décidé que ce serait
le son moyen d'encadrement principal de
la jeunesse en Italie et comme c'est une
institution interclassiste qui est
répandue géographiquement sur tout le
territoire à partir du moment elle
décide que dans ses patronages on jouera
au football en quelques années le
football supplante le cyclisme et
devient le sport national et qui dans le
cas italien il y a toute une théologie
du football c'est à dire pour être un
bon chrétien
on peut être un bon chrétien en jouant
au football et surtout ça explique même
le style de jeu italien c'est à dire que
le l'église de pidouze dans la praguerre
et une église autoritaire centralisée
donc le capitaine de l'équipe enfin les
joueurs doivent obéir au capitaine de
l'équipe comme les fidèles doivent
obérer au pape
un style de jeu très tactique très
discipliné où il s'agit d'assurer la
victoire de son camp face à un autre en
l'occurrence c'était contre les
communistes alors vous terminez ce livre
avec la France parmi ces histoires de 11
matchs il y a notamment
1998 la France qui compte parmi le plus
grand nombre de pratiquants en Europe
mais qui a mis beaucoup de temps donc à
remporté sa première Coupe du Monde vous
dénoncer d'ailleurs un certain snobisme
un élitisme antifood qui a parfois
méprisé le football comme un sport de
beauf d'ailleurs vous évoquez qu'Abu le
terme de beauf il vient de la caricature
de Cabu
un mépris de classe le politique des
lassera longtemps le poids sociétal du
football mais une année va changer les
choses c'est cette finale de 98 oui
alors en fait ça aurait pu changer avant
si on fait de l'histoire contre factuel
imaginez qu'en 1958 la France de Copa
fontaine bat le Brésil en demi-finale
imaginons Pelé le jeune Pelé a été
blessé à ce moment là comment aurait
réagi les élites politiques à ce
moment-là de Gaulle vient de revenir au
pouvoir il y aurait eu dans une
compétition un sport qui assure le
prestige national du pays peut-être que
là les élites politiques donc
économiques donc intellectuel ce sera en
parallèle du football ça a pas été le
cas et on l'a bien vu en 1998 quand on
voit Jacques Chirac dans les tribunes on
sent qu'il sait pas trop quoi faire il
faut qu'il montre qu'il est content mais
en gros il a jamais vrai il s'est jamais
vraiment intéressé au football donc il
faut crier le nom des joueurs ça tombe à
côté voilà mais à partir du moment où il
y a des millions enfin voilà la moitié
du pays devant la télé où il y a des
millions de personnes dans la rue
évidemment que les élites politiques
peuvent pas rester à l'écart d'un tel
phénomène d'une telle popularité qui l'a
a montré que elle pouvait être au
premier plan
les politiques doivent doivent faire un
peu le le leur procès dans tout cela et
revoir leur attitude mais la presse
aussi vous vous rappelez ce déferlement
de violence contre aimait Jacquet
ancienne ouvrier Fraser à Saint-Chamond
dans la forêt ce côté stéphanois
et qui va prendre sa revanche avec cette
finale de 98 mais qui aura toujours en
travers de la gorge c'est c'est
critiques de la part de la presse mais
c'est il est vraiment emblématique de ça
c'est quelqu'un de très compétent
d'ailleurs il a été entraîneur de
l'équipe championne du monde et voilà
c'est pas un intellectuel au sens où un
professionnel de l'information
c'est-à-dire qu'il a quelqu'un
d'expliquer ce qu'il veut faire et donc
là au moment de la coupe du monde ou bah
le par exemple la grande presse
parisienne commence à s'intéresser ils
ont pas un bon client entre guillemets
qui a toujours son accent son accent du
Forez et donc là bah oui il y a une
forme de mépris de classe sur le thème
s'il peut pas parler c'est qu'il est pas
compétent mais voilà il y a une
compétence dans le milieu du football
français voilà c'est on devient pas
champion du monde par hasard mais
justement il y avait pas encore eu ce
saut où en gros les élites
intellectuelles ou journalistiques
étaient capables de faire la médiation
entre la culture populaire pour la
rendre pleinement légitime dans la
société et la prendre au sérieux ce qui
agite beaucoup la presse maintenant
c'est évidemment la prochaine Coupe du
Monde au Qatar dans à peu près trois
semaines environ environnement droit de
l'homme corruption est-ce que mondial va
laisser les traces pour l'attribution du
Mondial à l'avenir l'attribution d'un
Mondial les capacités d'un pays organisé
les critères de de sélection il peut y
avoir une influration en gros sur la
capacité d'organisation la prochaine
Coupe du Monde on ira encore plus
d'équipes participantes on va passer 32
à 48 donc là il y aura besoin d'un
nombre de stades assez conséquent donc
forcément ce sera soit un pays
gigantesque comme les États-Unis soit
plusieurs pays
pour la suivante c'est ça donc en gros
des associations de pays pour avoir
juste le nombre de stades suffisants
ensuite sur le choix du Qatar par
rapport à notre pays c'est plutôt une
stratégie de mondialisation du football
c'est à dire que la FIFA depuis
d'origine a pour principal objectif de
diffuser et de contrôler la diffusion du
football et il y a des concurrents il y
a la NBA américaine il y a le cricket
dans une autre d'autres parties du monde
qui pour nous et c'est assez étrange
mais
il y a des milliards de gens qui jouent
au cricket aussi étrange que ça puisse
nous paraître et donc la FIFA est
toujours engagée depuis la fin des
années
2000 enfin depuis les dernières années
du siècle dans une stratégie de
mondialisation les États-Unis l'Afrique
du Sud l'Europe de l'Est avec la Russie
maintenant le Moyen-Orient mais un jour
il y aura la Chine un jour il y aura
l'Inde et donc c'est d'abord ça qu'il
est inquiète c'est continuer à rester le
premier sport du monde merci beaucoup
Fabien Archambault de nous avoir d'avoir
accepté notre invitation d'être venu ce
matin pour nous parler de coups de
sifflet une histoire du monde en au 11
matchs aux éditions Flammarion